my name is Navid Abed Zadar and I've
been working on the development of a
lossless electron beam splitter which
could be ultimately used in quantum
electron microscopy so traditionally the
way electron beam splitting has worked
is by passing a beam of electrons
through a thin crystal the periodic
atomic structure of the crystal would
diffract the electron beam and therefore
split it the problem with that is that
whenever there is electron going through
matter there is a inevitable losses due
to inelastic scattering and an
absorption
our approach is to use a diffractive
electron mirror which is a diffraction
nanofabrication diffraction grating with
a negative bias applied to it so what
happens is sinusoidal potential surfaces
form on top of this diffraction grating
and when an electron interacts with that
two things happen first of all because
these surfaces are negatively biased the
electron gets reflected and secondly
because they're sinusoidal in shape the
electron gets diffracted and that's
where the splitting happens and since we
didn't really go through matter all the
losses I mentioned earlier are not a
part of this design so ultimately the
hope is to use this device in quantum
electron microscopy which is a novel
electron microscopy techniques proposed
to allow for nanometer resolution
imaging of sensitive biological samples
such as proteins without all the damage
that's caused by the electron beam